I think it'll be better I think it'll be
better than me I got like three plates
in my room right now we've been
roommates for a year in a couple months
it was roommate at first like we've been
roommates since November 2015 and that's
six or seven months so one through the
other we're roommates and we're also
best friends we've been friends since we
were nine years old and we've been
roommates for about a year and a half we
did have like a period where we had to
like learn each other's here's guys
we've been roommates just short of two
years we didn't know each other at all
first year was a little rough we weren't
on the same page I did use your your
hair product today as well without
asking
how long is an acceptable amount of time
to leave washing up I usually do like a
couple of days I think it should be
within a 24 hour period what time should
you try to be quiet around the house oh
we're both like super quiet like a
little nice people typical our neighbors
probably don't really know all the time
all noise is bad yeah that's you you can
be as noisy as you want since you're
feeling yeah you find out a clean
underwear what are you - this is a
triggering question I stopped taking
your underwear you just been like years
since I took her underwear or year I
don't even wear six months I'm going
commando
by the way the same ones until I watched
new ones I would let you borrow my
underwear rather you walk around Terry
what foods are communal I did give pizza
Gary pizza dough Anja talks you I have
pizza that you could have - oh my god
Saturday we're pretty good at texting
each other and asking if we can eat
something Arthur drew maybe my third
roommate is you tested that with you and
your housemates discovered dead mouse
under your sofa what do you do oh this
is real rightness right now right away
screaming I'll remove the dead mouse
you and your housemates need to sort out
how to pay bills what do you do I think
no at this equation I usually just find
out what I owe I pay all the bills
bothers you the most
I just dirtiness I'm hosed a messy no no
it's not your house he brings the person
they're dating over for the first time
what do you do although we have such a
good story we have a feel-good don't
worry
hang around as much as possible maybe
follow them around
embarrassing I think I've done that yeah
you've done that your housemates partner
is spending more nights at your house
than not what do you do what she just so
you don't sleep you don't pay on it
someone has eaten the last cookie in the
packet you bought what do you do you
would shrug and say it's just a cookie
but you passive-aggressively be angry no
I screamed at him we did it we're so
friend she's a great roommate we're both
gonna be an 81 a couple months oh I
think the test is rigged oh I expected
this just told us the truth that once
again healthy communication is key I am
sixty two point I'm honestly shocked oh
yeah does your roommate like Masaccio
and cuddle you when you're having a bad
day cuz mine does yes we're fun but
definitely save up saving buy your own
place yeah that's the best on it